In the United States,
we have about 330 million people.
And because of the distribution,
relatively normal distribution of Iq scores,
about 16% have iqs of 85 or two means they're not going to graduate school.
No,
it means that from,
from what I've read practically,
it means the wonderlic company has actually done a really,
they have a nice I cute tennis from the commercial perspective,
you know,
it's actually psychometrically valid and they've linked Iq levels to,
uh,
to job specifically the job categories,
you know?
No,
not a lot.
I was going to say is they're not only not going to graduate school,
they're not going to find a stable job that pays a livable wage.
Yeah.
Now,
especially even given that so many of the service jobs now require a fair high
degree of computational savvy or leader built,
no,
not computation,
but ability to interact with complex computational technology loves the typical
till Latta and a checkout market or the till at a Mcdonald's because Mcdonald's
is actually very complicated,
is often far beyond the ability of people who are on the low end of the
intelligence distribution.
And they claimed,
I think it was wonderlic,
although it might know,
it might've been,
it might've been hunt.
What's his name?
Uh,
Iq researcher.
He said Earl haunt,
I think possibly what he claimed that that if you have an Iq of below 90,
that it's,
it's difficult.
It's difficult for you to read well enough to translate what you're reading into
action.
So you can't actually read instructions and follow them.
You don't have that level of literacy.
That's correct.
Yeah.
I was going to say that in,
in the United States,
this bottom 16% translates into 51 million people.
Right.
Including 13 million children who are in school.
This is a very difficult problem.
You know,
I knew where Ohio,
he passed away when I knew him pretty well.
He also would say that there is this a cognitive segregation in society.
This is a point that Charles Murray makes.
Yeah.
Well,
and Earl would often ask,
uh,
you know,
when's the last time you had someone over for dinner who wasn't a college
graduate?
Well,
that was something that Marie and her Bernstein wrote about in their book the
bell curve,
which really struck me because I read that book twice,
unlike most of the people criticized it.
And you know,
we're one of the things that they pointed out in there,
it was,
look,
the,
the typical,
the typical educated person thinks that someone isn't very bright if they have
an Iq of 150 grand.
How'd you at graduate level,
Phd level research institutions cause 115 there's,
there's as many people at 115 above as there are at 85 and below.
And so it's a minority of the population and that's the top 15% and you know,
that's,
that's the dollar undergraduate,
right?
So why don't you just,
people have to see,
I'm a clinical psychologist and I've dealt with people who,
how do I ranges in the low eighties and tried to find them jobs and tried to
train them.
And I have some real knowledge about the stunning gap between people at the low
end of the EICU distribution and the high end.
And it's,
it's no bloody wonder.
People hate Iq research and intelligence research because it reveals a set of
seriously,
uh,
dismal facts about the incredible range of ability among human beings.
Yes.
Um,
this is true.
And Moreover,
I would add to this that people in universities,
professors and couple of graduate students,
uh,
have a hard time understanding what the,
what everyday life is.
Like.
If you have an Iq of 85 and we're making your way,
you're living independently,
you were making your way in the world,
but it is a challenge.
It is a really,
I mean,
uh,
just,
just barely begins to describe it.
I had a,
I had a client who he probably had an Iq of under 80 and nonverbal portion of it
anyways.
And,
um,
he was indistinguishable in physical appearance from,
from let's say,
I hate to use the frame normal person,
but there's nothing mark that mark Timm out about,
particularly intellectually impaired,
you know,
and,
uh,
I tried at one point,
this is this,
this was so,
so telling to me.
I got him an inch,
a volunteer job,
which by the way,
it's very difficult.
It's harder to get a volunteer job in a real job because you have to do police
screening and all sorts of things.
And the selection process is just as extreme.
But I eventually ended up getting him a job at a bike store,
bike,
slash,
bookstore and at that place couldn't hold him once the subsidy program had
expired.
And then I got him a job at a charity and his job was to fold letters into three
so that they can be put into envelopes.
Well that sounds easy except that he also had a bit of a motor tremor and you
know,
it took me about 30 hours to train him to fold up a piece of paper with
sufficient precision so that it can be put in an envelope rapidly so that the
envelope wasn't so mangled that it would get stuck in the automatic sorting
machine.
And another is high performance demands on him too.
He had to whip through those letters pretty quickly and then sometimes the
letters would have a photograph appended to them that was stapled on and they
weren't always stapled on in the same place.
So then he had to calculate how to fold the paper over the photograph without
bending the photograph in precise third so that would still fit in the envelope.
And then he had to separate the French letters from the English letters and
associate them with the proper envelopes and like that level of complexity just
did him in.
Let me say two things about this.
One is I hope common sense and the other is pretty provocative but common sense
things.
We had to be very careful when we have these discussions not to devalue the
human dignity of people who aren't in the upper end of the distribution.
And if there's one criticism that I think is fair as sometimes in these
conversations,
it sounds like we're devaluing people at the lower end and the distribution and
we have to be very careful that we don't do that.
A human life has dignity and Iq was not the most important thing that defines
human gifts and beams.
EAGAN,
it's
not associated with wisdom.
It's not necessarily associated with truth or with courage or with many virtues
that
you like it at all with being likable there or on time.
How many of all,
we know the psychometric test,
the psychometric relationship between intelligence and conscientiousness is
zero.
Right?
We have to make that point.
Yes,
I agree.
I'm trying to make the point about how difficult it is for people who are on the
low end of the cognitive spectrum to survive in a,
in an increasingly complex,
cognitively sophisticated environment.
Right.
Your obs are just disappearing.